death it's one of the few things in life
that you can't avoid
along with taxes and plugging in a flash
drive upside down on the first try
statistically it can't be done
specifically this story is about the
people who investigate deaths when they
happen and if you're thinking I don't
want to see that on TV are you
completely sure about that because death
investigators aren't just supporting
characters on some of the most popular
shows like Law & Order SVU CSI and NCIS
every once in a while they even get a
show of their own think you can get away
with murder over her dead bodies ABC's
body approves smart is always better
when it's partnered with sexy Rizzoli
and Isles I'm New York City's top
medical examiner it's like I've been
doing this forever
well actually
forever yes forever which is also
precisely the wrong answer to the
question how long was that show on
television but but it's not just TV
death investigators who are very busy in
real life every year about 2.8 million
Americans die and most of the time a
position is the one who writes what
happened to them on the death
certificate
but if someone dies under suspicious or
unnatural circumstances their body may
be sent for further examination and
possibly a forensic autopsy that's what
happens to around half a million bodies
each year and those investigations are
incredibly important a death certificate
isn't like a degree from USC it actually
means something
autopsy results have huge implications
now there's the obvious one like
determining whether someone has been
killed and if so how but they also help
identify new trends in substance abuse
they warned us about defective products
and they can sound the alarm when they
spot the spread of an infectious disease
and people who work in this field take
that responsibility seriously I mean
we're on the front line of what's being
done what's what people are dying of we
see it every day
and we noticed a trend pretty quickly so
we wait to get the information out to
the public as soon as possible so that
other people are aware of what's going
on maybe prevent a few deaths if we can
right that's a very important point
about the public health role of her
office only slightly undercut by the
skeleton of Santa Claus behind her
though it seems for some reason died
with his dick in a box while it would be
great if those autopsies were always
performed and overseen responsibly as
local news regularly shows us that is by
no means the case tucked away in a
storage unit in Pensacola authorities
found more than a hundred human organs
the renter of the unit former medical
examiner Michael berkland the family of
an elderly murder victim is not happy
not at all they found out that two now
former GBI employees took a picture
holding the dismembered head of their
loved one we can't show you that picture
because it is too graphic so we're only
showing you part of it Shelley took the
Marines brain home with him to Virginia
removing it from a jar and letting his
kids play with it while his wife took
pictures okay okay so that's an
appalling story for a number of reasons
but most of all why did his wife take
pictures what was she going to do with
them post them on Facebook okay with
what caption Jackson and Faber Tim
Timothy handling a brain daddy's so good
to them always bringing home a new organ
for them to molest hashtag growing boys
hashtag god is good I look well those
are just individual examples of what can
go wrong the problems are much broader
with reports finding many death
investigation facilities are antiquated
and in need of repair or replacement and
given how critically important those
facilities are it is shocking how often
they're funded as an afterthought
currently the US government provides
virtually no funding to either medical
examiners or coroner's one of their
grants was for one office to get a new
refrigerator because their current
refrigerator was closed by a belt you
know that's how poorly funded
I myself have worked in an office where
it was a converted garage with a single
light dangling from the from the the
roof a single light bulb over my autopsy
table that is quite frankly too spooky
if I if I've learned anything from
horror movies is that when you see a
room containing one dead person one a
live person and one light bulb that's a
room that's about to contain two dead
people and one
so tonight learn from movies so tonight
let's talk about our death investigation
system specifically how it works
why it's such a mess and what we can do
about it and before we go any further
you should know that depending on where
you live or indeed die you could wind up
funnel into one of two systems around
two-thirds of the country's death
investigation offices are overseen by
coroner's while medical examiner's
oversee the rest now you might think
that those are the same thing and they
do have essentially the same job they're
responsible for deciding whether to have
someone conduct an autopsy and then
using it to rule on the cause and the
manner of death but there is a key
difference between them when it when it
comes to qualifications in particular
while medical examiners are required to
be doctors coroner's are usually not
medically trained at all in fact in
Georgia out of 154 coroner's only one is
a physician while the others include
grocers farmers handy men and
hairdressers which is a little bit weird
I mean no disrespect to hairdressers but
some have been known to drop the ball
from time to time mistakes have been
made and if you are wondering how the
hell grocers and hairdressers became
coroner's in Georgia as in much of the
country coroner's are actually elected
and the bar to run for the job can be
very low in fact in Arkansas there is
barely a bar at all you can run and be
elected with zero medical knowledge
anatomical training or official
certification of any kind you have to be
18 years or older you cannot be a felon
and you're electable holy look to
your right now look to your left both
those people are eligible to be and
indeed our coroner's in Arkansas and
having elected officials with no medical
training signing off on death
certificates is frankly weird enough
before you factor in the potential for
some huge conflicts of interest in some
jurisdictions the coroner is also the
County Sheriff and that has led to some
serious problems in California one
doctor quit a County coroner's office
claiming that the coroner / sheriff
there had repeatedly interfered in cases
where the police had used deadly force
dr. Bennet Omalu renowned for his
expertise on concussions accused San
Joaquin County Sheriff and coroner Steve
Moore of trying to change autopsy
findings in shootings involving his
officers that is obviously not good it
is hard to trust a death certificate in
a death involving police officers when
the guy signing it seems to have an
active interest in the police not being
culpable it is also hard to trust it
when the guy signing it looks like
Marlon Bongo made a wish to become a
real boy and it backfired
horribly
now now that's sheriff denied doing
anything improper but they've since
taken corner duties away from the
Sheriff's Office which is good because
you can't have any suggestion of
coziness between death investigators and
law enforcement in New Orleans their
coroner for decades was frank Minyard
who was criticized for frequently
finding that people who died in police
custody had suffered accidents and when
he was confronted over one case in
particular he got pretty annoyed when
the body of Henry Glover was found in
this burned-out car evidence pointed to
police officers being responsible for
his death but coroner Minyard
did not classify it as a homicide and so
there was no criminal investigation a
burnt-up body inside a burned-out car
well to begin with behind a police
station okay
look at it that way now look at it from
my point of view we can't say there's no
way I can say that that is a homicide
there's no way of telling how why this
man died except absolutely is a way to
tell how that man died a medical
investigation into his death which
happens to be your exact job he's like
hearing a clown say look there is no way
to twist this long skinny balloon into
the shape of a dog or a hat really clown
if that's true what exactly is the use
of you other than psychologically
damaging children for the rest of their
lives and incidentally that case was
later reclassified as a homicide because
of course it was and when you take all
of this together it is no wonder that
medical organizations have been calling
for the coroner system to be abolished
since 1857 arguing that the person
appointed should be a doctor in medicine
essentially the medical examiner system
which instinctively does sound much
better doesn't it although you should
know even this system is not perfect
remember the place where staff posed for
photos with a severed head that was a
Medical Examiner's Office the guy who
took the brain home for his kids to play
with
he was and still is a medical examiner
and that's not even mentioning the
medical examiner at the center of the
most fantastic 20/20 interview of all
time the other charges that your
dog ate one of the bodies spleen and
then he also ate a kidney is that true
dr. hunt
do you even want to respond you can deny
this if it's not true it's never
happened to me in an ABC News interview
before or since
but Charles Harlan fell completely
silent he didn't get up and leave he
just simply stopped talking what are you
doing camera no he's not used to dealing
with the living but playing dead is just
not a legitimate movie the problem is
though good medical examiner's can be
hard to find because it's not a job that
many doctors want you've already seen
the problems of underinvestment in the
facilities but on top of that
state-funded medical examiner's make
around half the salary they could in
other medical specialties with little
potential for tips from satisfied
clients and that is that that is just if
you're happy with any doctor in the job
the best-case scenario is to have
board-certified forensic pathologists
running these offices and performing
autopsies but that is not going to
happen anytime soon because there is a
dire shortage of those in fact there are
only 500 of them currently practicing in
the whole United States which is less
than half the recommended number and
when you combine this starfish shortage
with the current opioid crisis causing
an increase in bodies that need
examining you get assistant that is
pushed well past its breaking point in
New Jersey a few years back their acting
state medical examiner resigned in
frustration citing staff shortages as
one of the key reasons I felt as I
walked in the door they didn't have
enough personnel to to handle the load
you don't want to come to a family sit
I'm sorry ma'am I'm sorry mrs. Smith we
couldn't do the investigation that we
wanted because we didn't have the
resources right he wanted to serve
people well but he couldn't and things
have frankly not got much better in New
Jersey since so for the time being if
you do find yourself dying there please
write down whatever is killing you on a
post-it note and stick it to your chest
you
only be doing that overstretched
investigators are solid thanks the
resources crunch is so bad that some
offices wind up outsourcing work to
private contractors and this is where
this story gets absolutely incredible
because let me just introduce you to one
terrible example of this in Missouri in
Kansas a number of coroner's offices
wound up hiring a company belonging to
this man Shawn Parcells to perform
autopsies and why wouldn't they after
all he's a guy whose actual license
plate says autopsy that's immediately
reassuring isn't it
they don't just hand out to anyone with
a valid government-issued photo ID and
$45.00 know unfortunately though there
were a few problems with Parcells for
starters he's not a forensic pathologist
he's not any kind of doctor at all and
what he maintains that his firm employs
doctors he's been accused of performing
illegal autopsies himself and he has
frankly left a long trail of problems
behind him ourselves has been accused of
botching a murder investigation we
cannot use any evidence found from the
autopsy in a court of law and lying
about his credentials did you think he
was a doctor
why because I tell people all the time I
almost became a neurosurgeon that
doesn't mean that I'm a doctor that
doesn't mean that I was in medical
school I really did almost do that what
what you almost became a neurosurgeon
but didn't which puts you in a special
category of literally everyone on earth
except neurosurgeons I can also
claim I almost became a neurosurgeon
which is why my parents and this is true
are almost proud of me
and if you are wondering why a County
coroner's office would hire Shawn's
company remember many of them are
seriously strapped for cash and one of
them explained simply it was the most
affordable and Shawn's low rates become
understandable when you see one of his
autopsy facilities which for some reason
he was completely comfortable letting
cameras in herself gave us a tour he's
proud of this back-alley autopsy lab so
this is our the autopsy suite and
obviously bathroom there's carpet on the
floor what appears to be a lack of
organization and this is how containers
are labeled and stored I don't know
where okay
she's over there such as everybody we
agreed to not record a woman's body that
was unwrapped and unrefrigerated in the
back corner the freezers and it couldn't
be because there's no walk-in
refrigerator inside this makeshift
morgue only two small freezers that
could be purchased at any big-box store
okay okay so what jumps out at me the
most about Shawn's tricked-out death
hutch isn't the single Glade plugin or
the name's Shawn surrounded by green
hearts on the white board all the
Tupperware containers of baked ziti and
all human remains
oh the ominous presence of what appears
to be a spray bottle of Scrubbing
Bubbles multi-surface bathroom cleaner
or the absolutely sick lab of nerds
poster or the even sicker Albert
Einstein poster opposite the
room-temperature cadaver or the desktop
skull or the unfolded beach towel or
even the wall-to-wall carpeting no what
gets me is that even within a grifters
back-alley autopsy shanty the most
objectionable item on display there is
somehow that absolutely enormous soldier
what are you doing with that thing if
you monster
this this repurposed ramen container
could and I have to assume does contain
blood phlegm and embalming fluid and yet
it still would be significantly less
nauseating
than the possibility that he's drinking
a 40 of squirt that is that's just me
speaking personally as well as correctly
and objectively but wait because there
is even more here because Parcells has
also gotten in trouble for autopsies
performed but performed through his
private autopsy businesses for which he
often failed to produce any sort of
report all of which has led to enticing
pending criminal charges in Kansas of
theft and desecration of bodies and all
of this has clearly given him a bad name
in the business but rather than stopping
what he was doing Shawn Parcells simply
stopped being Shawn Parcells and instead
started working under the name professor
Lin and when that reporter asked him why
his answer wasn't great
when was used as a nickname
honestly I'm being honest here because
people would butcher my last name
I don't think Parcells is that difficult
it's not it really isn't
but I've had people say Purcell ease
parcel ease mailing you don't have to
pronounce it out loud no no okay so then
why are you signing things professor Lin
it's my middle name I have I have that
right so first that's clearly horseshit
and second the only person who should be
going by his middle name is Hugh Grant
whose middle name and this is true is
Mungo it's true his actual name is Hugh
Mungo Grant and for some reason he
chooses not to publicize that like an
idiot you're looking a gift horse in the
mouth
and look as funny as Parcells it is and
he is distractingly inconveniently funny
the reality is that he's botched
multiple death investigations and the
only reason he had the opportunity to do
so was because of the big gulp sized
holes in our fucked-up death
investigation system and the thing is it
is not just dramatic consequences of
murder investigations being compromised
or epidemics potentially being missed
even just ordinary delays in processing
death certificates can have serious
practical consequences for families
because ideally you'd want a death
certificate within days or weeks but it
can take much much longer than that just
listen to one woman whose husband had
passed away suddenly and who had to wait
six months for a cause of death
they're not thinking of these families
that are waiting in agony waiting to
know what happened to their loved ones
it's inexcusable to hold up also left
Sarah struggling financially because
without the death certificate she
couldn't collect life insurance to take
care of her family I couldn't pay for
the mortgage I couldn't I had to rely on
donations from friends and family to you
it's much more than just a piece of
paper yes to me it meant moving on
that's awful
you shouldn't have to wait that long for
something that important it's not like
making someone wait eight years to find
out who wins the game of Thrones don't
tell me who it is yet I haven't seen it
but based on the season so far I'm
guessing it was Ed Sheeran like they
really know how to deliver for the fans
don't like so so what should happen now
well in an ideal world no one would die
I'm certainly never going to and at the
risk of sounding too prescriptive I
don't think you should either
but in a slightly less ideal world we
would phase out coroner's offices and
replace them with medical examiner's you
know the thing that experts have been
arguing for since the 1800s and we've
have autopsies performed or supervised
by board-certified forensic pathologists
but that is not going to happen until we
address the huge personnel shortage you
can't hire forensic pathologists who
don't exist so we need to find ways to
it to incentivize medical students to
become forensic pathologists fire paying
them more and by properly funding the
offices that they're going to be working
and the crazy thing is it wouldn't even
cost that much
one study recommended bringing public
spending on these offices up to a
minimum of just three dollars 75 per
person per year that is less than the
amount of money that we inadvertently
annually donate so our couch
cushions and look I know this issue is
tempting to ignore it combines two
things that people hate thinking about
the most death and municipal funding and
nobody wants to contemplate their own
death or the death of their loved one so
try and think about this in a more
abstract way think about what you would
want for a beloved entertainer not me
obviously that's the worst possible
example think of Beyonce or Ted Danson
or Glenn Close do you want Glenn Close
to wind up in Shawn Parcells autopsy
dungeon or having her spleen being eaten
by a dog of course not
she's a seven-time Oscar nominee and she
doesn't want that to happen either do
you Glenn no I don't want my spleen
eaten by a dog show my spleen some
respect
[Applause]
Glenn Close deserves three things two
Oscars and not to have her spleen in by
a dog that's the very least America can
do for her and look we can and we should
improve our death investigation system
for Glenn Close and for every other
person in the country not just because
it's important which it is not just
because it could save lives which it
could but because all it will cost us is
roughly the same price as an extra-large
big dog
and now this and now a message about the
importance of death investigations from
Tracy Morgan Tracy Morgan and Oh can I
talk about something for a minute we all
know that one day we all will be on this
planet we're gonna die I don't know how
I'm gonna die but I know it's not gonna
be by Walmart when my time does come I
don't want to end up in a basement
dungeon on some dudes autopsy table
standing over me with a butter knife in
a dull spoon and an ice cream scooper
I don't want these things and please
please don't let someone take my brains
home to play with that's not a good
thing and I love this woman I'm telling
you right now I cannot have some dog out
here eating Glenn Close to the spleen
Glenn Close is an American treasure I
love you in Albert Nobbs that's why we
need you here
all it's gonna take us $3.75 to save
Glenn Close explain but you want to save
us play me down as a sunny five cent who
don't got that $3.75 all it takes
get out my house
[Applause]